6 ans plus tard ils ont préféré faire
l'union Jean-Marie Mison sénateur udi et
Catherine belrti sénatrice LR tous deux
sortant s'engage cette fois sous
l'étiquette majorité sénatoriale une
stratégie inspirée par des maires ne
voulant pas trancher entre eux c'est
encourageant et c'est motivant pour pour
pour nous en tout cas et c'est une forme
de récompense à nos yeux du travail
effectueux et d'une reconnaissance que
qu'ils ont envers ceux qui se sont
investis pour les communes face aux
grands électeurs les deux lfendent un
mariage entre républain et centristes
moi je suis fait partie de la majorité
sénatoriale de droite Jean-Marie
centriste mais nous travaillons ensemble
et bien souvent bien nous allons dans le
même sens que nous prenons des décisions
une union qu'ils espère voir remporter
deux voire trois sièges sur les C enjeux
dans le département pour leure ce choix
est bien ressenti moi je pense que c'est
le bon choix et nous ferons le maximum
de de voix c'est notre objectif mais gar
à la dispersion des voix car une dizaine
de listes se revendiquant de droite ou
de centre droit prendront le départ le
24 septembre à l'image de celle menée
par l'ancienne candidate aux élections
législatives Anne boucher qui concourt
sous la bannière horizon mais sans
l'appui de Renaissance et du MoDem le
parti horizon c'est pas un parti qui est
structuré comme les autres c'est un
parti dont l'échelon de base est la
commune et à travers ce parti horizon
Édouard Philippe souhaite redonner place
centrale au maire redonner du pouvoir
d'agir au Mair et remettre les maires au
cœur des des débats publics des
divisions il y en a également à gauche
de l'chiquier pour les socialistes
Jean-Marc todchimi sortant ne se
représente pas il a àoubé Michael Weber
maire de velflin les sargemines le
premier fédéral deosel a réussi l'union
avec le PCF mais pas avec les vers qui
ne constitueront toutefois pas de liste
aujourd'hui ça nous semblait important
face à cette division de la droite mais
aussi dans un département qui a plutôt
tendance être de droite d'avoir cette
liste d'union pour que un à minima
peut-être
deux sénateurs soit de soit de gauche
aujourd'hui clairement il me semble que
ce qui est engagé c'est vraiment la
bataille pour obtenir deux sièges à
l'occasion de cette élection sénatoriale
et pour y parvenir il nous faut cette
union une alliance décrié et qui
n'empêchera pas une liste communiste
dissidente menée par le chef de fil
départemental du PCF autre sénatrice
sortante au centre cette fois Christine
Herzog aimerait rempiler au Palais du
Luxembourg il y a 6 ans numéro 2
derrière Jean-Louis maçon elle obtenait
un siège à la surprise générale mais peu
de temps après son élection l'ancienne
maire d'erting se sépare de son
colistier jean-l basson fait sa
politique moi je fais la mienne pour moi
c'était très important que je reste
indépendante sans étiquette puisque
monsieur mçon a rejoint le rassemblement
national depuis les les régionales voilà
donc je me suis détaché de lui bon après
on est resté en bon terme mais
politiquement c'est important pour moi
que je me détache et que j'explique tout
cela
aux élus de de Mosel voilà c'était des
questions effectivement beaucoup se
posaient la question Jean-Louis maçon ne
se représentant pas le rassemblement
national y voit une auben le parti de
Marine Le Pen lance donc un candidat
Michel Rambourg maire de vancourt une
commune rurale de 76 habitants la
ruralité c'est l'âme de la France c'est
dans la ruralité qu'on fait le blé
l'élevage et cetera ce sont les deux
mamelles de la France labourage et
pâurage donc en partant de ce principe
de plus en plus hein les ruralités sont
oubliées hein n au niveau de
gouvernemental vis-à-vis disons en
privilégiant systématiquement les
grandes métropoles et c'est contre ça
que je veux m'élever une élection
moselan ouverte avec de nombreuses
listes qui pourraient réserver des
surprises avec deux sortants qui ne
rempilent pas le renouvellement du
paysage politique local est assuré et
voici l'ensemble des listes candidates t
mosell déposé en préfecture vendredi
dernier je vous rappelle que cinq sièges
sont à pourvoir dans ce département
l'élection sénatoriale on le redit ce
sera le dimanche 24 septembre on suivra
bien sûr tout ça sur notre antenne pour
compléter ce reportage
on